[Music]
twenty years ago and you would lead
detective on the Big Smoke case right
[Music]
I'm a journalist
why this case all point to you
a murder like that only goes unsolved if
the police don't want to solve I've seen
the water book you have a suspects
20-plus years and not one arrest
are you guys hearing to pop shooters
were hired by Biggie's entourage
we didn't have to park him the facts
point is a little more the we could
proof of connection between cop and
Biggie's murder
can we not only break the LAPD it would
ruin the city
[Music]
why don't you attacked LAPD's connection
they're all records I cannot comment on
an open investigation it's an ongoing
investigation that evidence stays locked
away in the dark
[Music]
we are a match stick away from
blood-stained streets every day
[Music]
you have no idea what the LAPD is
capable of we are distancing ourselves
from the story got what I need
[Music]
beast was
it was only one way this was go ahead
[Music]
you